so girls what are we going to do at the
weekend then
don't drop that crisp packet on the
floor okay
put it in the bin is that your chris
pacquiao it may seem like nothing to you
but have you any idea what can happen
when you upgrade it on the floor
we're now going to tell you
a story
of discarded
questions
here
is a discarded
crisp packet
but i have my revenge
so the crisp packet blew around down
around
until it caught a gust of wind
we flew it straight into the path of an
unsuspecting cyclist who lost control
and then the crisp packet blew around
and around and let another crisp package
and they joined together
and they blew down the drain
and they blocked the drain up so when
the winter came and the rain came
rain
overflow to the waters industry and it
flooded
and then the crisp packets
floating down into the sea
where an unsuspecting dolphin
swallowed the crisp packets
and
died
next time i'll put you in the video hey
one piece of rubbish
ass up
into
a huge
pile
of rubbish
become a killing crusader
just
so
so
you